♪
>> Greg: HAPPY WEDNESDAY, RIGHT?
IT'S WEDNESDAY.
SO ABOUT THAT STEERING WHEEL
STORY.
IT WAS A BOMBSHELL, ALL RIGHT.
MINUS THE SHELL PART.
JUST LIKE ALL THOSE OTHER ANTI
TRUMP BOMB SHELLS.
AT THAT TIME JANUARY 6TH
HEARINGS YESTERDAY A STAR
WITNESS NO ONE EVER HEARD OF
TESTIFIED ABOUT SOMETHING SHE
DIDN'T SEE WHICH RIGHT THERE
MAKES HER TESTIMONY AS LA JETS
MATE AS SMOKE SIGNALS FROM LIZ
WARREN.
SO WHAT'S THE GIST?
THAT IS THEN PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP WAS BEING DRIVEN BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER THE
JANUARY 6TH RALLY AND DEMANDED
THE CAR PULL OVER SO HE COULD
SNACK ON AN INJURED DOG ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD.
YEAH.
IT WAS A PEKINGESE WHICH HE THEN
SLEUTHERED IN KETCHUP WHICH HE
DEVOURED WITH HIS HANDS.
DON JR. WAS IN THE BACK SEAT.
SHE WAS TOLD THAT ANYWAY.
ACTUALLY SHE WAS TOLD ON THE WAY
TO THE RALLY DONALD TRUMP
STRIPPED NAKED DECLARED HIMSELF
THE KING AND ALL OF SHAKESPEARE
PLAYS ON HIS SMITH CORRESPOND
'RONA PROCESSOR HE BOTHERED FROM
HIS HEAD ADOLF HITLER WHO ISN'T
REALLY DEAD BUT LIVES IN A
SHAMPOO BOTTLE IN MAR-A-LAGO
POOL HOUSE.
MAYBE THAT ACE BIT MUCH.
BUT HER CLAIMS ARE EVEN MUCH
BELIEVABLE.
SHE CLAIMS SHE WAS TOLD THAT
TRUMP ACTUALLY TRIED TO GRAB THE
STEERING WHEEL FROM A SECRET
SERVICE AGENT.
THE VERB USED LUNGED, HE LUNGED.
YES, LUNGE, THE THING MY
PERSONAL TRAINER MAKES ME DO BY
HOLDING MY DAIQUIRI OUT OF ARM'S
REACH.
ABOUT EIGHT INCHES.
BUT, YEAH, TRUMP APPARENTLY
CRAWLED OUT THROUGH THE BACK
WINDOW OF THE BEAST.
THE BEAST, WHICH IS THE CODE
NAME FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL LIMO,
AS WELL AS HILLARY CLINTON.
SHUFFLED ACROSS THE ROOF, THEN
SLID DOWN IN THROUGH THE
DRIVER'S SIDE WINDOW TO GRAB THE
WHEEL WHILE SCREAMING SCREW THE
GUNS LET JESUS TAKE THE WHEEL.
SOUNDS REAL, RIGHT?
GOOD THING WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN
THERE TO KEEP IT ALL ON THE UP
AND UP.
I KID.
BUT IT'S ODD HOW LIZ CHEYNEY HAS
BECOME THE VINDICTIVE EX-WIFE
THAT DONALD TRUMP NEVER KNEW HE
HAD.
NOW A SCREECH OWL WITH THE FAKE
SERENITY OF A STEP FORD WIFE.
YOU GUYS DON'T STREP STEPFORD
WIVES?
THE PEOPLE WHO SPENT FOUR YEARS
TELLING YOU TRUMP WAS SO OUT OF
SHAPE ONE FOOT ON THE GRAVE AND
THE OTHER ON A PACT OF MAYO NOW
WANT YOU TO BELIEVE I SLITHERED
AROUND A MOVING VEHICLE LIKE HE
WAS JACKIE CHAN.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S IN REAL
TROUBLE NOT LEAST FOR ASSAULTING
HIS SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
>> I CONFESS, I CANNOT RECALL
EVER HAVING HEARD ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF A PRESIDENT TRYING TO
PHYSICALLY HIJACK HIS OWN
MOTORCADE.
>> TO GRAB THE STEERING WHEEL, I
MEAN, IS DANGEROUS, DANGEROUS
ACT.
AND THEN WHATEVER, TO GRAB THE
SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
I MEAN, THIS, THIS IS BEYOND
THAT TRUMP WAS THE WRONG MAN FOR
THE JOB.
>> THAT'S GOING TO SIT FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, YOU KNOW,
ATTACKING HIS SECRET SERVICE
AGENT.
>> Greg: HA HA, ATTACKING.
THE MEDIA HASN'T BEEN THIS
EXCITED ABOUT AN ATTACK SINCE
YOU KNOW WHO.
DUSTY, YOU'RE BACK.
OF COURSE LIKE THE SMOLLETT
STINKY TAIL THIS FALLS APART
LIKE A CHEESE STEAK IN A HOT
TUB.
I TOLD THEM THIS WAS A CHEESE
STEAK.
SORRY GOVERNOR.
FIRST OUR VERY OWN DAVID SPUNT
WHICH IS THE PAST TENSE OF SPAT
CONFIRMS ON BACKGROUND BOTH
CONFIRMED ON THE ANTIDOTE
DISPUTE THE LUNGE AND PETER
ALEXANDER ALSO A SOURCE CLOSE TO
THE SECRET SERVICE SAYS BOBBY
NGLE AND THE LEAD AGENT THE
DRIVER ARE PREPARED TO TESTIFY
UNDERSOCIETY THAT NEITHER MAN
WAS ASSAULTED AND THAT MR. TRUMP
NEVER LUNGED FOR THE WHEELS AND
ABC'S JOHN SANTUCCI THEY TOLD
HIM THE SECRET SERVICE WILL PUSH
BACK AGAINST ANY ALLEGATIONS OF
ASSAULT OR TRUMP REACHING FOR
THE WORLD NOR GOOD DID HE
SUDDENLY GROW EIGHT FOOT RUBBER
ARMS LIKE HE WAS IN THE
FANTASTIC FOUR.
FINALLY CNN ADMITS YES, AN
OFFICIAL DENIED SAYING AN AGENT
TOLD HUTCHISON THIS STOEFRMENT
EVEN CNN.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOSE CNN, YOU
KNOW, YOU LOSE CNN AND ITS
REMAINING 12 VIEWERS.
ACTUALLY IT'S ONE VIEWER BUT IT
GOES BY THE PRONOUN THEY.
THERE'S MORE DISPUTES OVER WHAT
HUTCHINSON CLAIMS.
SOMETHING ABOUT A NOTE SHE SAYS
SHE WROTE BUT DIDN'T.
MAYBE, I DON'T KNOW.
WE COULD GET INTO IT BUT WE'D
GET A MORE BELIEVABLE DRIVING
STORY FROM PAUL PELOSI.
IT'S ALL CLOAKED IN OVERWROUGHT
THAT YOU ARE AND NOT EVEN GOOD
LIKE YOU SEE ON BROADWAY BUT
COMMUNITY THEATER LIKE THE PLAY
YOUR AUNT MARGARET HAS THE LEAD
IN.
WHICH IS WHY THE HEARING'S A
JOKE.
IT WAS A ONE-SIDED SHA RAID THAT
UNDERMINES EVERYTHING PRESENTED
WHICH IS WHY NO ONE WATCHES IT
UNLESS IT'S FORCE FED TO THEM BY
THE MEDIA.
THEY THOUGHT A HEAVILY PRODUCED
SPECIAL CREATED BY AN ABC
PRODUCER FEATURING CAMEOS BY
PEOPLE YOU NEVER HEARD OF WOULD
BLOW YOUR MIND BUT FAILED LIKE A
REMAKE OF THE LOVE BOAT.
EVEN TESTIMONY FROM CHARRO CAN'T
SAVE THEM.
I'M OLD.
HONESTLY, HOW MUCH OF THIS GUY
DO YOU NEED TO SEE?
YOU KNOW IF I WERE CYNICAL I
WOULD SAY HE'S A USEFUL IDIOT, A
GLUT ON FOR STRANGE NEW RESPECT
FROM HIS TEMPORARY LIBERAL PALS.
HE ALWAYS LOOKS LIKE HE'S ABOUT
TO BURST INTO TEARS.
WHAT DOES KINZINGER MEAN THE
GERMAN, ANYWAY?
KAREN?
YOU KNOW, HE SHOULD SAVE THAT
FACE FOR WHEN HE GETS A JOB
DRIVING LIZ CHEYNEY TO MSNBC.
YEAH, POOR LIZ, A FATAL
ATTRACTION LEVEL STALKER WHO
CAN'T GET OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHICH REMINDS ME, DONALD.
HIDE THE BUNNY.
THESE REFERENCES, THEY'RE SO
OLD.
I GET THEM THOUGH, AND THAT'S
ALL THAT MATTERS.
THE FACT IS THE COMMITTEE
THOUGHT THIS WAS A SLAM DUNK.
A SHOW TRIAL FULL OF SECONDHAND
ACCOUNTS.
WHO WOULD COMPLAIN?
THE MEDIA?
NAH, THEY'RE LAUGHING IT UP LIKE
IT'S AOC BATH WATER.
WATCHING IT REMINDED ME OF THAT
GAME WE PLAYED AS KIDS BUT YOU
SAT IN A CIRCLE AND WHISPERED
SOMETHING TO THE PERSON NEXT TO
YOU UNTIL IT WENT ALL THE WAY
AROUND THE CIRCLE AND BY THE END
IT WAS TOTALLY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WAS WHISPERED AT THE START.
I THINK IT WAS CALLED SPIN THE
BOTTLE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT HEARSAY IS.
AND I'M NOT EVEN SAYING IT'S
FALSE.
WHY BOTHER WHEN THE COMMITTEE IS
FALSE IN THE TRUEST SENSE OF THE
WORD.
IT'S THE BIG RED BOW ON THE BOX
OF CORRUPTION BROUGHT TO YOU BY
THE SAME CLOWNS THAT CREATED
HOAXES FOR SIX YEARS IT'S
PREPPED TO SAY HEAVILY PRODUCED
PROPAGANDA.
I KEEP WAITING FOR A PROPAGANDA
TO SAY CUT, LET'S DO THAT AGAIN
WITH A LITTLE MORE FEELING ADAM.
DESIGNED NOT TO UNCOVER TRUTH
BUT DISTRACT YOU FROM THE REAL
TRUTH OF CRIME INFLATION
IMMIGRATION ALL THE THINGS THE
ADMINISTRATION FAILS US ON A
MASSIVE SCALE.
BUT WE SEE THROUGH IT LIKE A
CONDOM STRETCHED OVER A
FLASHLIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I KNOW.
FACT IS WE KNOW TRUMP HAS A
TEMPER.
I STILL REMEMBER THE WEDGIE HE
GAVE ME AFTER I REPLACED HIS
DIET COKE WITH PEPSI.
I'VE NEVER BEEN LIFTED THAT HIGH
IN MY LIFE.
SO HAPPY.
FACT IS THEY CREATED A SHOW
TRIAL BUT FORGOT TO BRING THE
SHOW APPEAR NOW THEIR HONESTY IS
ON TRIAL, TO WHICH I SAY LOCK
'EM UP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE'S SO PATRIOTIC MOUNT
RUSHMORE TAKES FIELD TRIPS TO
SEE HER EVERY SUMMER.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR AND AUTHOR
OF THE NEW BOOK NOT MY FIRST
RODEO, KRISTI NOEM!
SHE TALKS SO FAST SHE MAKES SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS CALL IN
SICK.
OUTNUMBERED COHOST EMILY
COMPAGNO!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HIS JOKES HAVE HIM
LAUGHING ALL THE WAY TO THE
BANK, THE FOOD BANK.
ACTOR WRITER AND COMEDIAN JAMIE
LISSOW!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] PUSH
PUSHING
>> Greg: AND SHE BRINGS OUT THE
BEST IN PEOPLE WHEN THEY REPORT
HER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
GREAT NEW BOOK GOVERNOR NOEM.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT SURPRISE,
YOU HAVE AN AMERICAN FLAG ON IT.
>> Gov. Noem: I KNOW SHOCKER
RIGHT?
>> Greg: I KNOW.
>> Gov. Noem: SHOCKER.
>> Greg: AND YOU'RE ON A HORSE.
>> Gov. Noem: DID YOU REVIEW IT
ON AMAZON YET?
>> Greg: NOT YET BUT I WILL.
>> Gov. Noem: APPARENTLY THAT
REALLY MATTERS.
>> Greg: I'LL DO THAT TONIGHT.
>> Gov. Noem: THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
>> Greg: I'LL DO THAT TONIGHT
AND I WON'T EVEN READ IT FIRST.
KIDDING.
SO ABOUT THESE HEARINGS, HAVE
YOU BEEN TUNING IN OR WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THEM?
>> Gov. Noem: I HAVE BEEN TUNING
IN AS LITTLE AS PUSHABILITY I'VE
BEEN PAYING ATTENTION BUT I
CAN'T HONESTLY FOCUS ON IT.
HOW CAN YOU?
WE'RE LITERALLY MAKING STUFF UP
NOW.
I HEARD A RUMOR OUTSIDE THE
GIRL'S BATHROOM THAT MAYBE THIS
HAPPENED EIGHT, NINE, TEN MONTHS
AGO BUT I'M NOT SURE.
OKAY, YOU SWEAR UNDER OATH?
YES I SWEAR UNDER OATH THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED.
IT'S LITERALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN WASHINGTON, DC NOW.
I THINK THIS GOVERNMENT HAS
FALLEN TO THE LOWEST LEVEL I
COULD HAVE IMAGINED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT KILLS ME
ABOUT THIS, TOO?
IS THAT, OKAY, THIS IS NOT OVER
YET.
>> Gov. Noem: NO.
>> Greg: IT'S OPEN-ENDED.
A, IT'S OPEN-ENDED AND B, WHO'S
PAYING FOR IT?
WE ARE.
>> Gov. Noem: YOU'RE NOT PAYING
FOR IT?.
>> Gov. Noem: YOUR CHILDREN, YOU
GRANDCHILDREN.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THAT FOR A
LONG TIME.
>> Greg: SCREW YOU KIDS.
I WIN AGAIN.
>> Gov. Noem: ALWAYS WINNING,
TIRED OF WINNING.
>> Greg: TIRED OF WINNING.
THE REASON IT DOESN'T END IS
BECAUSE WE'RE FOOTING THE BILL.
>> Gov. Noem: I KNOW, I KNOW.
>> Greg: IT'S INSANE JAMIE.
>> Jamie: IT IS.
>> Greg: ARE PEOPLE WATCHING
THIS IN ALASKA.
THEY HAVE TELEVISIONS, AM I
RIGHT?
>> Jamie: YEAH, WE DON'T CABLE
BUT WE DO HAVE TELEVISION.
THIS CNN THING, MY GOODNESS.
THEIR VIEWERSHIP IS -- THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO START CALLING
IT NOTHING ANYONE WANTS TO CNN.
TALKING ABOUT THE SECRET SERVICE
FOR BEING THE SECRET SERVICE I
FELT LIKE THERE WAS A LOT OF
NAMES AND FACTS THEY PUT OUT
THERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO START
CALLING IT CAN'T KEEP A SECRET
SERVICE.
I GOT REALLY WORRIED, NOT
WORRIED BUT I WAS THINKING
ABOUT, WOULDN'T IT BE CRAZY TO
HAVE LIKE SECRET SERVICE LIKE
FOLLOWING YOU EVERYWHERE HOW
CRAZY THAT WOULD BE.
AND BY THE WAY JUST
EXAGGERATE -- LIKE YOU SAID SAY
IT IS TRUE HE REACHED FOR THE
WHEEL.
HE'S NOT A TERRORIST.
HE'S NOT ATTACKING ANYONE.
I THINK BIDEN WAS JEALOUS LIKE
OH, MAN, I JUST HAVE A LITTLE
TOY WHEEL IN THE BACK.
I'M JUST GLAD NO ONE FOLLOWS ME
AROUND BECAUSE --
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: WHY?
>> Jamie: REMEMBER THE SHOW
CHEATERS?
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Jamie: REMEMBER THAT?
I FEEL LIKE IF THEY FOLLOWED ME
PEOPLE WOULD TELL ME EX-WIFE,
OH, WE THINK HE'S CHEATING ON
YOU, HE ORDERED TWO DINNERS FROM
CHIRPING CHICKEN AND THEN THEY
WOULD BUST INTO MY ROOM AND IT
WOULD JUST BE ME EATING BOTH OF
THEM.
THEY WOULD BE THE GOOD NEWS IS
YOUR HUSBAND'S NOT CHEATING ON
YOU.
THE BAD NEWS IS, HE'S A SLOB.
>> Greg: TRUSTING AND SAD TALE.
>> Jamie: UH-HUH.
>> Gov. Noem: WE'RE THERE FOR
YOU.
WE GOT YOUR BACK.
>> Greg: WHEN THE GOVERNOR SAYS
THAT.
>> Gov. Noem: YEAH.
>> Greg: I THINK SHE'S LONELY.
>> Gov. Noem: I'M A REALLY GOOD
LISTENER.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT EMILY, YOU'RE
A LAWYER, OR SO YOU CLAIM.
WHAT IS LACKING IN THIS
COMMITTEE, THIS HEARING?
>> Emily: SUBSTANTIVE DUE
PROCESS.
I MEAN, I WILL SAY THIS IS ALL
ABOUT HOME FIELD ADVANTAGE,
RIGHT?
THIS IS JUST LIKE A GRAND JURY
PROCEEDING WHERE IT'S ABOUT THE
PROSECUTION, ALL HEARSAY RULES,
NO OBJECTIONS, NO
CROSS-EXAMINATION, THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER, AND THAT IS
WHY GRAND INJURIES LEAD TO A
99.9% INDICTMENT RATE.
AND THE OTHER DIFFERENCE IS THAT
GRAND JURY PROCEEDINGS ARE
SECRET USUALLY WHERE THIS IS
BEING PLAYED OUT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
AND TO ME THE CREDIBILITY ISSUE
HERE IS THE FACT THAT THESE GUYS
ARE HOLDING THEMSELVES OUT TO BE
THE ULTIMATE FACT FINDERS.
THESE ARE THE INVESTIGATORS,
SFLIET WHEN IN GRAND JURY
PROCEEDINGS, THE WHOLE POINT IS
THAT THAT KICKS OFF WHEREAS ONE
OF THE FIRST STEPPING OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCEEDINGS,
RIGHT?
THEY GO THEN TO TRIAL.
THEY GO THEN TO BRING CHARGES.
BUT HERE OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD
BE A REFERRAL, BUT THEY ARE
HOLDING THEMSELVES OUT AS THE
ULTIMATE COURT AND, FOR SURE, IN
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION,
THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT THEY CARE
ABOUT THE MOST.
>> Gov. Noem: AND ELECTION.
>> Emily: YEP
>> Gov. Noem: AND THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT.
>> Greg: I KEEP GOING BACK TO
THE FACT, THERE'S NO
DISINCENTIVE TO STOP.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN DOING THEIR
JOB.
WE'RE PAYING FOR THEM CAMPAIGN
AD.
THIS IS AN ENTIRE CAMPAIGN AD.
IT'S CRAZY, KAT, ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY.
WILL YOU EVER MAKE UP STORIES
ABOUT ME?
>> Kat: I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: FAIR ENOUGH
>> Kat: BUT NO THIS WAS POPPING
UP ON MY PHONE LAST NIGHT AND I
DIDN'T EVEN CLICK ON IT WHICH IS
WILD.
>> Greg: YEAH
>> Kat: BECAUSE I LOVE TEA, YOU
KNOW, AND THIS SOUNDS LIKE THIS
WOULD BE SOME CRAZY TEA.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
TEA?
>> Kat: WHATEVER.
I CAN'T MAKE YOU YOUNGER, SO --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I KNOW THE PHRASE
>> Kat: IT REMINDS ME I ACTUALLY
HAD A FRIEND, USED TO BE MY
FRIEND, HE TOLD THE BEST STORIES
UNTIL I KEPT CATCHING HIM LYING
AND I JUST LOST INTEREST.
HE SAID TO MARKS HE WAS LIKE YOU
NEVER ASK ME ANYTHING ABOUT MY
LIFE.
I'M LIKE, YEAH, BECAUSE I NEVER
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME
ABOUT YOUR LIFE IS ACTUALLY YOUR
LIFE AND I ACTUALLY REGET
LISTENING SO INTENTLY YOU TOLD
ME ABOUT THAT STORY ABOUT YOU
AND HARRY STYLES IN A HOT TUB.
WHICH HE DID TELL ME.
DON'T THINK IT WAS TRUE.
AND LIKE I'M THERE TO BE A
FRIEND BUT I DON'T WANT TO BE
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THE TEST
AUDIENCE FOR YOUR EROTIC FAN
FICTION.
BUT IT'S THE SAME, IT'S THE SAME
SORT OF THING HERE WHERE IT'S
LIKE HOW MANY TIMES CAN THINGS
TURN OUT TO BE, YOU KNOW, SOUND
REALLY EXPLOSIVE THAT TURN OUT
TO BE N